j'ai beau avoir 23 ans
j'ignore des tas de choses sur moi quel
est mon profil psychologique quelles
sont mes compétences en métallurgie ou
encore elle était adoptée
mais aujourd'hui grâce à des quizz
certifié par les gouvernements français
je fais en découvrir beaucoup plus sur
moi même écouter aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il est temps que j'ouvre mon coeur et
que nous découvrions tous ensemble qui
suis-je vraiment viard une série de quiz
à vue tous certifiés par la science ou
le gouvernement vraiment pas par contre
certifié par ce quiz et ça je peux vous
dire qu un truc est certifié par squeeze
olalalala c'est que c'est vraiment pas
où ça fait longtemps qu'on sait pas fait
une petite vidéo on fait des tas de quiz
j'en ai trouvé des peintres au mal des
sympas dont certains que j'ai vraiment
envie de faire et que j'ai pas vu le pam
spoil j'espère que tu seras pas du coup
la douche froide devant des résultats y
ne serait pas totalement humiliés devant
vous tous mais aujourd'hui ces quizz
vont répondre à des questions
existentielles que je me pose depuis des
années comme par exemple quelles races
de chiens y tue très important dans une
vie
maintenant passer un vrai test que j'ai
toujours voulu faire mais je pense que
c'est une version altérée c'est pas la
vraie version du test de ross a choisi
cachir horde h
alors ce test là c'est le test où on
regarde les fameuses taches d'encre et
on doit dire ce qu'on voit ça a été
créée en 1921 donc c'est très vieux
c'est un test d'évaluation psychologique
tout simplement pour en savoir plus sur
quelqu'un alors faisons ça et apprenons
nous en plus sur moi ça me fait mourir
de rire que le résultat soit méga creepy
et que des millions de gens
s'aperçoivent qu'ils suivent un mec méga
creepy et pas du tout bien meilleure ça
me fait rire que voyez-vous deux
vieilles femmes bossu des poumons
une femme portant une longue robe
fourreau de voyageurs avec un sac à dos
une chenille mecque et ben honnêtement
ce que je vois le plus ces deux vieilles
femmes bossue j'ai l'impression qu'ils
savaient pas forcément dire quelque
chose de bien de voir deux vieilles
femmes bossu mais on y va wahou qu'est
ce que c'est que ça un papillon un
fossile une fleur exotique
un coléoptère l'infini au col aubeterre
pas mal mais un coléoptère c'est à dire
ah ben non mais pas du tout j'ai
confondu un coléoptère avec le jeu c'est
même plus d'où ça vient le truc qu'on
envoie en l'air qui ajuste une aile et
qui tourne en rond comme sa clémence te
plaît montage pour montrer aux gens j'ai
l'impression que pour celui-là on voit
tous un papier mais peut-être que je me
fais des idées que j'ai du mal à
comprendre que tout le monde ait pas
comment comment vous sentez-vous à la
vision de cette image comme ivre agité
détendu je ne sens rien excité jeu sans
rien du tout mais que c'est vraiment les
images qui étaient à la mode sur google
en 2007 devant lesquels je ne ressentais
d'ailleurs déjà rien vite fait que voyez
vous un verre à vin ou deux hommes mais
tu vas toujours plus voir leblanc avant
le noir non olala je suis surpris en
train de dire un nombre de trucs faux
incalculables on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis la vidéo sur les pyramides mecs
faut que j'arrête de d'avoir des
déductions pour y aller deux hommes est
là que voyez vous un crabe une araignée
une tête de bélier un volant de moto je
fais de la moto mais là faut vraiment
être un gros gros biker un vaisseau
spatial des nuages dans le ciel
je vois des trompes d'un utérus mais du
coup ce pas dans les propositions donc
suis-je extrêmement étrange peut-être
que c'est juste la conséquence de mes
cours d'svt qui m'ont beaucoup marqué
bah vous allez vous tapez une grosse
barre mais comme j'ai fait de la moto
sur piste hier et on dirait vraiment
l'avant d'une moto ça c'est les phares
saas et les rétroviseurs ça c'est la
petite bulle à volants de moto déjà y'a
des mecs comme butin un volant de moto
il n'y a pas de volant sur une moto je
doute totalement de la qualité de ce
test là d'un coup d'oeil on va dire un
truc de moto y at il un mouvement mais
c'est à une
d'optique mais tout le monde voit un
mouvement c'est une illusion d'optique
qui marche surtout les êtres humains oui
ça se trouve je suis insupportable et je
crois que ce que moi je vois tout le
monde le voit mais en fait non j'arrête
d'être insupportable comment ça que
voyez-vous aucun ça me fait mal aux yeux
4 5/5 certes non mais maxi à la réponse
ça me fait mal aux yeux ce test n'a plus
rien d'officiel arrêté fait des vrais
tests cool alors 1 2 3 4 4
je voyais vous ici un oiseau un masque
vénitien une femme avec un collier
ethnique wade pied un coeur un éléphant
un masque vénitien ça c'est le masque
des médecins de l'époque une photo mais
dans le cas paraît ici vous voyez pas ce
masque moi je vois ça un rapide coup
d'oeil que voyez vous je vois des jambes
en l'air
ouais mais c'est parce que j'ai regardé
le haut de l'image avant le bac quand je
regarde le bas je vois des chaussures à
talons et quand je regarde le aux joies
des chaussures plates
j'ai vu les jambes en noir en premier
qui est ce que je suppose ce qu'ils
appellent légende d'hommes aient enfin
ici que voyez vous je vois un élève de
cm2 qui a éclaté sa cartouche d'encre au
dessus de son cas et là il est dans le
mal et ils essaient de cacher les
preuves avant que son professeur le
voyais le punisse voilà ce que je vois
pas pourquoi c'est pas dans les réponses
alors ok quiz hautmont beaucoup with dis
moi ce que je suis vraiment tu es
extrêmement passionné vous vivez tout
intensément que ce soit dans le travail
la travers tes relations d'un fils
s'il vous plaît faites un effort qu'on
fait d'un test pour que le mec le faste
se sentent un minimum bien et crois que
c'est un minimum sérieux entre le volant
de la moto et la faute d'orthographe
dans la conclusion s'il vous plaît à
travers les relations d'amitié ou en
famille vous montrer toujours un
engagement à 200 % ou décupler chaque
instant et vivez votre vie avec passion
mais autant est-ce que vous suivez pas à
youtube heure extrêmement passionnées
base à ceux qui disent que je fais ça
pour l'argent là je suis juste
extrêmement passionné c'est le test
qu'il a dit personne peut remettre ça en
question quand même test suivant j'ai
envie de me laisser guider retour dans
le passé combien de vies as tu déjà vécu
voilà c'est trop là ok on va faire un
test aujourd'hui que vous attendez tous
depuis des zones quel métier aurais je
fait si je n'avais pas été youtuber si
ça n'avait pas marché comme si je
n'avais pas eu la chance que j'ai envie
je connais déjà la réponse je vous la
donne avant vendeurs de jeux vidéo à
micromania
je sais c'est le média cliché mais
franchement j'aurais adoré mais c'est un
site s'appelle top métier c'est
peut-être plus ou moins sérieux comme ce
test là on va voir l'idée aujourd'hui
est de proposer un test d'orientation
gratuit et sans inscription qui va
t'aider à trouver l'emploi taillé sur
mesure pour toi en moins de cinq minutes
chrono ne te proposeront trois jobs avec
des liens vers les fiches métiers
correspondants est ce qu'il est possible
qu'ils te propose le métier de youtube
heures aubade en leur proposition serait
marrant adacore le test gratuit mex
tu coches trois points forts et trois
points faibles c'est quand même très peu
d'infos pour ensuite définir quel métier
est fait pour toi base il va faire et
espère en moi je veux savoir s'il me
sort vendeurs à micromania mec je vous
jure je leur donne ma chaîne youtube
alors si je devais écrire un roman je
veux vite sur net pour pomper une idée
ce que je fais depuis dubaï donc j'avais
pas copier mais je ne déborderaient pas
d'imagination pour cet exercice même
occasion voyage débordent d'imagination
mon lieu de travail plutôt bureau plutôt
voyager air pur ni l'un ni l'autre et
ben franchement même si je pense que
beaucoup de gens adorent voyager air pur
wade dans un bureau je kiffe ma relation
avec les gens j'ai eu un contact facile
jeu plutôt renfermé nino et ben
étonnamment je suis plutôt renfermé ok
c'est vrai dans la vraie vie est dans la
vraie vie c'est autre chose que les
vidéos il ya comme j'ai dit j'ai fait de
la moto sur piste là et avant il y avait
un briefing et chacun à leur tour les
gens devaient se présenter et [ __ ] ça
m'a fait comme joueur quand j'étais au
lycée j'angoisse et où commence à se
rapprocher de moi j'en bois si
j'angoissais et au final j'ai eu de la
chance mon tour a sauté ils ont fait
parler le gars qui était après moi et
m'ont frappé la chance de ouf
d'incapacité travail je suis fatigué je
me lève tôt je me couche tard chez une
petite nature j'aime rentrer tôt du
boulot ni l'un ni l'autre
non mais c'est les extrêmes quoi c'est
soit et infatigable c'était une petite
nature ya pas l'entre-deux sur ce site
tout n'est pas tout blanc ou tout noir
nuancer les choses un peu mais moi je
suis clairement infatigable je me lève
tôt je me couche tard je mets tout ce
qui m'arrive et je suis un passionné bon
sens d'organisation je suis très
organisés chez pas organiser je suis
très tête en l'air je suis organisé mais
je traitais dans l'air ça marche
remettez l'un et l'autre alors je vois
un animal mort au bord de la route en
quoi ça va m'aider à trouver mon métier
expliqué moi je fonds en larmes très
sensible sur un point qu'absolument rien
chez moi non mais mec c'est un extrême
ou l'autre c'est un truc de quelqu'un
agressent votre copine vous le tuez où
vous ne fait rien on va plutôt dire je
fonds en larmes très sensible au niveau
scolaire je suis nul je toujours été
parmi les meilleurs ni l'un ni l'autre
la réponse ni l'un ni l'autre est fait
pour ça finalement les aptitudes
scolaires je suis très beaux mots ça y
est on est pas dans l'extrême ils sont
dit on est peut-être un peu extrêmes on
va se calmer gibbons logique et en maths
mon côté artistique baisse du seuil à
mes questions mais quand on se retrouve
ce soir à 1h du mat après les 1000
questions qui restent
mon métier de prédilection webmaster
bornes informatiques artiste est
organisée je ferai un très bon au
webmaster hockey programmeurs bon en
logique geek dans l'âme et ayant une
préférence pour la vie de bureau je
ferai un bon programme heures ok c'est
marrant aussi parce que mon père est
programmeur lui pour le coup donc c'est
rigolo inspecteurs d je pensais pas
qu'un jour dans ma vie un mec me dirais
mais toi tu est fait pour être
inspecteur des impôts tu t'es vraiment
fait pour ça à l'écouté des autres
organisés j'aime travailler dans un
bureau il ferait un très bon inspecteur
des impôts d'accord ou si vous êtes à
l'écouté des autres organisé et que vous
aimez être dans un bureau vous devez
faire inspecteur des impôts
s'il vous plaît pas écouté j'ai bien
chier sur ce test mais en fin de compte
c'est assez juste le résultat pour moi
donc faites gaffe à vous payer vos
impôts là sinon moi j'arrive je débarque
en y campe redressement fiscal dans
google immédiatement ok bon on passe
maintenant aux choses sérieuses quelle
maison je rejoindrai dans harry potter
rien n'est plus révélateur que ça sur ta
personnalité rien même si je suis
serpent tard je vais perdre la moitié de
nos abonnés ça montrera à tout le monde
que je suis une vilaine personne alors
l'une ou étoiles
étoile c'est plus loin ça me fait plus
rêver noir ou blanc
blanc comment voudrais tu que les gens
se souviennent de toi dans l'histoire
legrand lesage l'audacieux ou le bon
hyper prétention qui m'appelle lucas
hochart quoi le bon le grand qui es tu
pour dire que tu es bon grand et c'était
quoi l'autre lesage à lesage c'est pas
mal mais c'est prétentieux aussi je
dirais l'audacieux quel instrument plaît
plus à tes oreilles à intéressant à un
piano percussions violon ou trompette à
ces trompettes ou piano j'irai piano
j'adore site intégré howard quel animal
aimerais-tu prendre avec toi un chibani
nous bien évidemment il y aura par une
chouette un crapaud un dragon chat blanc
pour un chat siamois ce peut être pas
malsain tard la nuit du marche tout seul
dans la rue tu entend un cri particulier
que tu crois venir d'une source magique
qu'est ce que tu fais tu sors ta
baguette et tu reste sur ses positions
c'est jouable tu restes dans l'ombre
attend de voir comment la situation
évolue tout en passant en revue
mentalement l'essor de défense et
offensif le plus approprié
seulement neuf ça c'est le premier de la
classe a clairement qui va pour
découvrir la source du bruit tu vas voir
avec prudence en gardant une main sur ta
baguette dissimulé et un oeil à la
recherche de tout dérangement ouais je
fais ça moi je fais ça mon attention les
textes officiels en plus et jk rowling
manas est la vérité de la vérité absolue
quand je suis je suis
ouf un mec c'est pas le truc le plus
claqué c'est pas genre les gens vraiment
basique et genre vraiment normaux genre
ceux qui n'ont rien du tout de ce
spécial non c'est ça pouf c'est les
boules
bah ça se voit à leur [ __ ] d'un signe
d'ailleurs il est complètement nul
désolé à tous les poufs sauvegarde mais
admettons que notre maison n'est pas la
plus haute enchère est de tests frangins
thèse c est humain tellement enfants
ados ou adultes
sajan est de savoir quelle couleur
préfères-tu couleurs vives pastel noirs
blancs vivent donc faire ça mais dans la
catégorie enfant est ce qu'on aime les
couleurs vives on a un enfant et quand
on grandit on aime le noir et blanc on
devient très classique oh là là on ne
put rien de flashy 2 qui divertit wii
une console tests d'entrée du comment te
décrirais-tu intelligent et sophistiquée
je suis sophistiqué ok mais m ont mis
beaucoup de temps un mail à bord et est
si souvent ils se sont beaucoup
impliqués joyeux et curieux rebelles et
audacieux et je suis un rebelle de ouf
car activités préfères tu jouais lien
n'a rien faire à jouer comme ça fais moi
un enfant parce que je joue à 23 ans
chez un adulte et je devrais juste aimé
lire c'est ça tu as un peu sur la
défensive en l'ex hôtesse des gens de
l'est même tu le plus les dict histoire
de science-fiction en direct des images
parce que j'aime les livres avec des
images ça fait de moi un enfant c'est ça
chez supergiant que vraies vertus boire
du vin du soda du jus de fruits de l'eau
l'eau c'est la vie dans 10 20 ans y en
aura plus j'espère que non alors est-ce
que du haut de mes vingt trois ans je
suis un adulte
[Musique]
voilà un peu plus gras mais je vais
arrêter les fautes de grammaire et le
vocabulaire un peu trop jones vous
regardez un adulte là ok vous lui devez
le respect à cet adulte à la discussion
elle va elle va m'achever tuer quelqu'un
de mature de ouf
moi j'ai toujours sérieusement et c'est
que la vie ne se montrent pas toujours
très facile oh la la c'est vrai que moi
ma vie elle est pas facile hein alors
bon je me donne les moyens en cas de
problème tu garde la tête froide et
c'est régler les conflits avec
diplomatie
je suis le mec le moins diplomate
bon les amis ont fini avec le dernier
quiz qui est pas mal tourné sur les
réseaux le test de pureté allez c'est
parti
j'ai peut-être montré direct les
résultats puissent vous savez je crois
qu'il est vraiment très long ce test là
mais je vous assure que je vais tout
faire avec honnêteté et sincérité
les résultats sont donc les vrais
résultats qui représenteront totalement
ce que je suis
woerth c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est ce
test officiel posté par le gouvernement
je suis un youtuber saint partager ma
chaîne youtube à tous vos amis du coeur
de s'abonner de mettre des jamais de
regarder les vidéos jusqu'au bout car je
suis dit vas j'ai triché et bien écoutez
vous allez voir la fin de cette série de
quiz qui m'a beaucoup amusé et j'adore
les quizz c'est un plaisir visage me
souviens quand j'étais petit et que j'ai
acheté des magazines là quand j'allais
en vacances j'ai acheté genre 6,7
magazine à vous acheter et je prenais
toujours les magazines il y avait plein
de quiz dedans extérieur puisque j'ai
adoré qu'on me dise ce que je suis étant
donné que je ne savais pas que j'étais
bon maintenant ça a un peu changé je
m'en fous un peu mais ça fait marrer de
découvrir le quiz et de d'essayer de
voir ce que la personne qui a créé le
quiz a voulu faire comment elle a
orienté ses questions pourquoi la mittel
choix etc
c'est le beau jour je mettrai le lien
dès que le sujet fait en description si
vous voulez les faire mais ne prenait
pas s'envoyer de rien attention je veux
pas que vous prenez une décision
importante de votre vie en vous basant
sur un quiz
ça c'est non mais des fois ça peut aider
ça peut aiguiller sap orienté quand
c'est des vrais quiz officielle et pas
des trucs à la con comme j'ai fait là
mais je crois le truc pour trouver un
peu quel métier de plairait c'est pas
mal quoi c'est pas mal
voilà c'est mon avis deux mecs qui
finalement n'a pas eu un vrai métier bon
j'espère en tout cas que maintenant vous
avez conscience que vous suivez le
meilleur des youtuber le plus pur le
plus sain franchement un moment faut
rétablir la vérité
[Musique]